nous vous en parlions déjà hier soir
l'autre actualité marquante c'est la
fermeture dans l'agglomération
tourangelle dès aujourd'hui de trois
nouvelles galeries marchandes et qui
dépasse les 20 mille mètres carrés de
surface et finit par exemple le shopping
au sein de l'espace commercial de la
petite arche à tours-nord une bonne
partie des trente deux enseignes ont dû
baisser leur rideau jusqu'à nouvel ordre
une décision qui tombe en pleine période
des soldes et qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
lucas chopin 15h30 hier le couperet
tombe
les commerçants de la galerie marchande
de la petite arche à tours nord doivent
fermer leurs portes
résultat 27 boutiques prise au dépourvu
face à un arrêté qu'elles ne comprennent
pas ça allait appeler tous les clients
pour qu'ils viennent récupérer leurs
vêtements neufs
moi j'estime qu'on est essentielle quand
même aux gens qui travaillent légende 1
0 les gens des hôpitaux etc
ils ont besoin les jeunes et les
étudiants ils ont besoin aussi qu'on
leur lave leurs vêtements ce qu'on a
beaucoup et moi personnellement ne
comprends pas ce décret est dès lors
difficile de comprendre pourquoi des
commerces
anciennement essentiel ferme quand
d'autres comme le chocolatier ont le
droit de rester ouverts aujourd'hui un
sentiment général domine et forcément de
l'incompréhension les boutiques et le
centre commercial ont mis en place des
protocoles sanitaires on l'a vu faire la
queue avec distanciation social devant
les boutiques le gel pour se laver les
mains le masque forcément la circulation
avec le masque donc je pense que toutes
ces mesures réduisent
le danger le régisseur de la galerie
réfléchit d'ores et déjà à l'après
comment fidéliser des clients absent
pendant plusieurs semaines
faut pas baisser les bras les
commerçants sont suffisamment impacté
par les nouvelles
le but ça va être de travailler dur pour
pour refaire venir la clientèle ramené
de la joie de vivre et du dynamisme au
sahara au sein du centre commercial
auchan la guitare en attendant de
nouvelles directives les rideaux de fer
restent baissés le click and collect ne
devrait pas non plus être mise en place